Hello everyone, I'm English.In this channel,
I'm
making videos about careers in the tech industry. ー
some border 4 a doodle
voodoo good srp school e to do a peace force
voodoo
re weber render aso peropero learning endnote 4
se 52 to do
voodoo feister japanese for a 4 f do do
our upneeds
voodoo roodoo 4 se blues wither
render  to do
movie war league rausu t nester jeans for use up
teaser rain goods for a who do
eh green re japanese 4 re 4 as far apg murazu
for me phase de weather world diffuse hikokura italy
rde saramander forever re pap doe
sender
I don't have that kind of confidence, but I can speak normally, read and write
normally.
I'm really grateful to be able to talk with grandma reader free
n3 star Suwazawa Iku Variety tb Gendramanse k pop star ardrone
breno rudo
voodoo ono asino world are asan pendlower
jr japanese moomin app up as pou dou dou 4
Including fashion and move can 4 x welcome loose
middle find people t turk tu amazing that makeup s find
people who do me
After I became an adult, I really thought that I should create a Japanese-speaking bar.
The fighting me me in fun to do so wow
finding japanese all right calm early show 2
room ear ascender ender ender ore to do
b
andere to do
rear the voodoo  Wheelroll 14th moon
boo boo enoden dare you do
voodoo forever Lesson a year 20 speed fares 4
kids to do in
anorexia ndege Goods orenge Ah Ranger 2 do Talking
is a dream Ah Ah, Kansai dialect followed by sole management s car  It's really fun
to talk about surfing with a good family, and
I've recently realized that it's had a big impact on my identity,
so when I have children in the future, I'd like to teach them Kansai dialect.  But,
well, I want to teach you at least Japanese.
Formerless preen no turn signal lever voodoo
pou dou dou
rename to do
arso binding faren refuse to do do
4 meses per me to do
sa pou dou dou
voodoo forever re swear to do
rear japanese meeting
forever reru eater
on face keren osk
reir arthur style gui  Fire legs are you doing
I think the reason why Japanese is the language for my body is because my body is Japanese
Mmm greeting kind away game I'm coming home loose all
star s child with snake wish for a reason
japanese wow I
want to make a Japanese only
video soon  I think
so I mostly use Instagram to collect the questions, so
please follow me if you have any.
parent thyme dub 4 f and aaren who do
bd re in some power canine effector 6
bye